if i give you absolute power would you
be able to uh what would you how would
you change what does absolute power mean
like you said to me listen you are going
to be the dictator of planet earth and
anything that you want is at your means
including violence sex no
i would not
because even in my personal life now
there are things that i could do
right that i have power i guess
that i don't participate in right so why
would i do it if i had ultimate power
i mean because there's always there's
still a moral and ethics that i have
right that i don't feel
comfortable with right so you wouldn't
even enjoy it
no i mean i think that um there would be
no if i had ultimate dictatorship on
planet earth there would be no violence
i mean i would not cause any wars right
but if there's an uprising yeah i'd have
to quell it
that's how it starts bobby you quell it
don't don't surprise
right but so first you're gonna
censor everybody who wants to even
suggest the idea of uprising and then
and then one person gets out of line
they run a red light okay
that's that's
but you never get angry in traffic
yeah
i get rageful so if you could murder
that person no
no no no
nobody has to know
no i would give them cancer
but i would have so much
i know i know okay no but no here no
this is an interesting thing because i
want i want to elaborate all right so
the thing if i was the dictator of the
planet earth right um there would be a
reason why people would uprise right so
give me a reason
because i would give them food
shelter
right and all the things i feel like
that people would desire right
but you're right but you're right
because they're you're right i think
this is what you're talking about yeah
so here's the deal
so there are certain things that i do
believe in right like for instance it's
a very controversial thing right
in terms of a woman's right
right in terms of abortion right i feel
like as a male i
it's not my body so i don't really even
have an opinion and i shouldn't even
have a voice on it because
you know i mean a woman like it's like
if they created laws if white people men
created laws for koreans
in america like you don't have the right
to
right so it's like
so if i was if i was a dictator right i
would just be like yeah women have ever
all the rights in the world right and
they you know and i think
abortion should be legal throughout the
planet earth right but there will be
people out there that will believe that
no you know what i mean
we you know
we're pro-life
so you would put them in jail just so
that's right so i think as a dictator
you there was no way to be able to
please everyone so there will be an
uprising yeah so yeah [ __ ] it i don't
want to do it okay would you do it
uh
not
no there's several loaded questions
would i enjoy it
no
would i
uh do it no because i don't trust my own
mind under power like i'm well aware
that
in situations where i have control it's
it's
as much of freedom as it is a burden
like it can change you i'm very nervous
about that
interesting like how much uh
uh how much the ego starts to flare up
how much
just like the
less
uh pleasant things about your nature
come up you know i have a temper too
like i have all that kind of stuff
and uh you have i'm sure you have a bit
of a temper yeah i have a temper yeah
and so whenever nobody is able to
as clearly call you out on your [ __ ]
that's
that could be a problem do you have this
when you you when you rage on you have a
temper is there like
like either a day later or a couple
hours later is there shame and regret
that comes along with that or no
yeah no no no of course yeah during it
yeah during it too yeah shame and regret
yeah yeah and then but i try to make
sure
it's like love and respect are felt
always underneath the whole thing
um
but still it's like human emotion you
can't control it
and if you give an absolute power you
start to lose your sense of the world
you start to be unable to see what is
right and wrong you think everybody
everything is right
you start to be
um have a distorted view of who is doing
the wrong things in the world and then
also distrust
well that has to do more with how
absolute power is usually attained
because when you're in the seat of power
everybody first on the outside but then
in your inner circle you start to
distrust them you start to believe that
they're going to
they want your power so the people you
love the people that were source of so
much
beauty for you previously uh like even
like
your girlfriend wife your closest
lifelong friends you start to suspect
them i don't want to live like that yeah
yeah yeah and you're often right to
suspect them
so because you think they change a
little bit too they change too yeah they
start a little bit taste of that power
yeah it was the interesting thing is a
bunch of people in the in hitler's inner
circle at the very end betrayed him too
in in search of their own power wow it's
fascinating it's fascinating this power
thing
you